so um you thought about suicide every
minute of every day
what are the pros of suicide in your
mind at that time what at that time the
pros were
no one has to deal with this anymore
i don't have to feel this way anymore
i'm a burden to my family i'm a burden
to the military system i'm
weak i'm a bad soldier i didn't do my
job i don't deserve to be alive i don't
deserve
veterans affair support i don't deserve
my my parents don't deserve to watch me
go through this the guy i was dating
didn't deserve to put up with the
[ __ ] i put him through
the people who drive with me in cars
didn't deserve to almost hit medians
because i swerved because of a piece of
garbage
people didn't deserve my racist
outbursts people didn't deserve
people didn't i did not deserve to be
breathing anymore i should have died
there and i wished i died there
so um self-hate there too oh
not even a big deal though right
that's at the core of it that that's
like this um
so uh
how do you escape from that place how do
you overcome that
those
that depression essentially at the core
of the desire to kill yourself what um
what basic principles i mean we could
talk about ayahuasca but
basically principles of like literally
like
how do you escape that moment yeah
previous to any of that i i did from
2009 i got out so i was medically i was
3b medical honorable discharge in 2011
may 23rd 2011. so i left the military
then and so it's been 10 years
just over 10 years oh my god it's 10 and
a half years i just realized that right
now oh my god happy anniversary thanks
man awesome
so i've been out for 10 years and i
would say the reason i didn't kill
myself
for the longest time was the individual
i was dating
that that was that was straight across
the board that was it
um
for me
there was no relief for about
six years of the
the thought of just kill yourself kill
yourself killers it's easier if you just
do it like that voice was so strong for
that long there was really no relief
what there was though
was
implementation of different medications
realizing they weren't working
trying different things
getting myself to a point where i could
leave my house comfortably comfortably
ish again and i wasn't triggered which
then allowed me to travel which then
allowed me to
slowly try to go back to school which by
the way was a very bad idea that was a
bad idea that was that was bad
i went too early
they started practicing active shooter
drills in our school it was it was a it
was bad my professors understood
school is full of triggers it turns out
um it is when you live in vancouver
there's a theme to this conversation
about your love for canada i look at me
i love my [ __ ] country i am one of
the most patriotic people you will meet
in it i think canada is one of the
greatest [ __ ] places on the earth
i think in the past two years or three
years i have seen what i loved so deeply
so proudly preached about so
i'm so proud of what i did there
and i'm so proud of the country i got to
represent
because i was good at my job
being being great at your job for a
country you love you just don't like
some of the politicians some of the time
it's not even the politicians anymore
it's the state of the country
i'm a second-class citizen in my own
country right now
i can't travel to see my parents within
my own country
i'm not allowed to step foot in my son's
school
i'm
not allowed to go to a restaurant with
my family
i'm not allowed to leave canada without
i told you all the stuff i have to do to
get here
to even get home i have to do the same
i'm watched by the rcmp
i'm
neighbors rat you out
so so for somebody who fought for their
country i hate it it makes me so sad to
be to go through this process of uh
what many considered to be power
overreach by government in the face of
uh this particular pandemic
yeah
yeah i always knew i had a hard time
with like i loved canada the day i got
spit on when i got home was not ideal
but
yeah spit on yeah um
[Music]
but the thing was
i knew long enough that if i
just put one foot in front of the other
and kept going to treatment
and kept
doing what my doctor told me to do
that i could pull out of this
if i if i tried i i was told that i
could do anything in my life
it didn't matter
as long as i tried was trying really
hard
trying was
trying was harder than breathing
it it was exhausting it was
i would be awake for like half a day and
every minute of that day i'd just stare
at the wall and just want to kill myself
yeah that's what i've um had people
close to me who suffer from depression
and it was like
it's unclear how to escape but it's
clear they need to try some something
and they didn't want to even try because
you have no try in you yeah you have no
no i'm watching a person who has no
energy essentially to like do any of it
and it's like so hopeless
but you have to try and i think some of
that has to do
with all the different physical feats
you have to do like when you have
nothing left you still keep going that
same like weird
drive when you're empty you still keep
going
um i wanted to give up i tried i
it's i did i'm really lucky because it
really was the one person that
i'd wake up to next every day
and he'd be like hey so
that new drug you're on fun fact if you
don't go to sleep right away you talk
and when you talk you just don't [ __ ]
stop and you go off about everything
that's horrible and i'm like what are
you talking about no last night yeah you
took that pill guess what you just you
just you didn't stop i have no
recollection i'd get up in the middle of
the night i would cook food
like on a stove and it would be
hopefully we don't die because i would
have no recollection because of the
drugs
the idea that
when people say well just pull yourself
out of depression
i'm a highly motivated individual
the idea of lifting my head up to turn
over
was daunting
that's terrifying it's like for somebody
so as driven as you to completely lose
all of that for moments of time
for stretches of time
you